[Music]
welcome back to off the record what are
we talking about
whatever we want hey we have new father
timmy delegate over here
let's turn up guys hello
[Laughter]
what's something from your life that you
used to do that you can no longer do
that you miss
jack off you know i attack up a lot yeah
more now yeah yeah especially right now
she's just so tired from the baby
i'm like all right y'all are asleep at
9pm she allows you to jack off
oh yeah she loves that jagger that's
cool she's just kind of cause she i mean
she knows i'm a horny boy yeah um
and she's kind of like she doesn't want
me to be like frustrated
yeah that's nice so sometimes i'm like
all right babe i'm gonna jack up the guy
and have fun
it's hard it's hard to do sexy times in
the first couple of months
yeah why because their [ __ ] ripped up
no everyone's tired dude and everyone's
just tired
everyone's a doctor by the way that's a
[ __ ] doctor
that's a medical term you know i
diagnosed her with the rip the [ __ ]
yeah but no uh she's all she's all
healed up she's just tired okay
so jacking off a lot for sure but i mean
that's nothing new
i was always kind of jacking off a lot
um
something that i something i used to do
that i can't really do anymore you know
what i can't just
like if someone wants to spontaneously
like
yo i gotta shoot uh tomorrow can you
make it i need somebody or
um yo come through to this event like
tomorrow night can you come to them like
bro
now everything is like let me know two
weeks ahead of time because i don't want
to just
the baby's so new and she's like
consistently like she's breastfeeding
only right now
so it's like chia if i leave her alone
she is either breastfeeding or not doing
anything else so it's like
i gotta handle other [ __ ] while she's
feeding the baby so i can't just
bounce you know what i'm saying i'm like
if you want me for [ __ ] let me know like
two weeks ahead of time you never
thought about having
family members come yeah yeah and then
just be like stay with me and help me
but even that takes scheduling like you
know when people like
ask me to do things if i could get jio's
mom to come but that still takes the
scheduling where i still have to well
give me at least three days to get you
an answer yeah so i can see if someone
can come in
i can't wait till my stepdad dies my
mom's gonna be bored as [ __ ] and i'll be
like get your ass over here
i got a baby that's popping out so i'ma
time it perfectly where
his [ __ ] old ass is gonna croak my
mom's gonna be lonely as [ __ ]
i'm gonna have an extra house on the
side for
her where she doesn't have to annoy me
yeah and then i'm gonna pop out a kid
somewhere
and then i'm gonna just drop it off at
the house
for her that all makes like perfect
sense actually it checks out yeah you
should expedite the process a little
yeah
yeah kill them yeah get rid of them oh
yeah that's a good idea
i'm not ready i'm not ready to have kids
yet that's like one of your go-to
ideas on everything no but like he
keeps her company and i'm not ready to
have a kid right now it's
like the timing is everything right if i
[ __ ]
off him now she's gonna be calling me
every day because she's bored
and i don't have any [ __ ] kids to
kind of throw at her so it's like
yeah what am i gonna is there a certain
amount of time that you get that you
give the mom-in-law like as far as like
it's like hey bart come to my house this
weekend
and then you have like a certain amount
of time where it's like i have to ask by
this day or i have to
so for me personally i have to gauge a
lot of things
so one i have to gauge like how much
family time we've been spending because
i'm already a busy person and i feel bad
if i'm like
even less so there's that i engage and
then the second thing i gage
is you know grandma helps out all the
kids because they all got grandkids and
stuff so many kids
so if she's already been babysitting for
this kid and that kid and that kid and i
know
i don't even want to be the fourth
person
so there's like so many layers of
gauging of like
so sometimes i don't even ask somebody
and i just can't do it you don't you
don't call and be like you ain't doing
[ __ ] get your ass over here
i know if barney does it at 5 30 in the
morning i know
come on you ain't doing [ __ ] oh you're
asleep you have time come on
you should get the grandma and like an
assistant schedule everything out you're
just supposed to be our assistant
dang i'm not she's too busy what about
your mom
yeah but if she was here i didn't want
her okay because i was gonna add that
because like i was like which would you
do would you take the help
and deal with the annoyance or would you
rather have her away
with my mom yeah nah my mom has
so high energy like she wears taika out
really
yeah like she's just i don't know she's
crazy what about you would you would you
deal with the annoyance
with that for the help you know i
wouldn't mind especially if i had like a
super busy
time that i was like working a lot
shooting a lot but to be honest though
like
my parents are kind of getting old old
you know i'm saying where
i'm like like 70s like that my dad
is 70 yeah or he'll he's turning 70-ish
and um well 70. and how do you know
they're getting old
well just because for me i'm at a point
where i'm looking at them and i'm like
they just they look weaker
you know what i'm saying and like where
i'm yeah
well that happens i know what you're
talking about though i know you're
talking about so when i see my dad like
coming up the stairs to the house and i
see like he's like yo he looks winded i
don't know if
they'd be able to just spend a whole day
with the babies
there's that too yeah there's like hey
dad can do me a favor and he seemed to
go up the stairs like
i never mind oh [ __ ] my mom's a [ __ ]
geezer dude she's she's 76 and my
stepdad's 80 something
damn yeah and i i think they could
[ __ ] handle the kid
only because i want them too
i like to go visit my dad and this was
like
i don't even know if he had his hearing
aids in or like because he's already
deaf right
right this whole answers the door and he
just starts yelling at me so
every time he starts yelling at me i'm
always like what the [ __ ] is hearing its
art in
are they not turned on or like you try
to pull it out and
see if it's on and put it back in the
battery still working well like so
there's two things that
tells me that he's old as [ __ ] one he's
yelling at me all the time now because
he's deaf
and the other thing is his i think parts
of alzheimer's is starting to creep in
oh
[ __ ] i could change the topic on him at
any time and he's in the new thing is he
that old i think it's just starting like
he was like hey you gotta help me call
it uh my for some reason my phone
doesn't work or whatever right and i'm
like
all right i gotta take a piss oh you
gotta take a piss right okay you gotta
go to the bathroom right here and i'm
like
dad i used to live here i know the
bathroom how old is he like 70
71 this year he's not that old i know
but you could see
you can see you could see the sharpness
like
not be there holy crap like eating [ __ ]
yeah he was younger that story is so
good 60 yeah
okay he was probably six but you could
you could just tell like i'm like whoa
my dad is has like his reflex like are
you there mister like
he did age though cause like he looked
yeah i don't know was he able to really
move his head in there
ever since he told that story i just
think yeah dude like was he really
mowing that thing yeah i caught his dad
motorboating his girlfriend's [ __ ]
i i i for some reason i watched the
sherry episode where you were
kind of retailing i'm familiar
no like so my dad my dad's moving to
vegas too right and originally how i
planned it
i was just gonna take him sunday morning
and go check out houses and come back
with them
but then seeing how he it takes him
more time to do things i'm like oh [ __ ]
i don't think he could do like this
young person same day thing
so now i'm going to take him like
saturday night so he has time to like i
think old people need to move
move chill move move chill mm-hmm and i
don't think he'd just be like on the go
like that anymore so my stepdad is kind
of a
different guy than because he's in his
mid 80s
and he does the dance like you're dead
does the ballroom dance
she also didn't meet him when he's 50.
so you don't know
if he devolved or not you just know him
yeah because he used to ride motorcycles
and [ __ ] and and i heard that he had
much more energy
yeah so this might be his because i'm
just comparing my dad to what i knew of
him oh
when he's keeping active doing stuff
that probably helps because like my
parents aren't really i mean my mom does
her gardening and stuff but like my
dad's not really like out there doing
anything you know what i'm saying so i
feel like
he's just not as active so so sometimes
like the other day he got a little
pissed at me because he was coming up
the stairs of my house
and i'm like you're good and he's kind
of like just watching me watch him he's
like i'm
fine i can go up the stairs you know i
can't imagine what that's like though
it's it's trippy bro and look and also
it's a little different
it's a little trippier because you know
my mom always used to get a hair done
like you know so it was always kind of
black right and then because of the
pandemic
she's all like grayed out now it's like
oh [ __ ] y'all are
actually looking kind of old now for the
first time
you know like like ever you know i'm
like wow i see the girl looks like a
raisin dude
like a [ __ ] you know those raisins that
used to dance and [ __ ]
that's my mom california do your parents
do your parents have plans of getting a
one-story house
um you know they they were thinking
about selling the house in paramount for
a while because like you know
it is two stories but um my mom like
loves the house so much she has her
whole backyard garden so
i think they're chilling and honestly i
kind of feel like at least they have the
stairs that that's a little workout for
them
a little something that you know get
their juices going jesus
that's all they got for workout man
life is bleak when you're old i don't
know if i want to get there
are your parents at that age or not just
my parents are like 65
yeah so they're getting up there damn
all our parents are about the same age
yeah yeah not mine they're [ __ ]
ancient compared to your guys yeah
but i have a brother that's 12 years
older that's why so then if you guys are
the oldest or
close to that it makes sense today's
video is brought to you by
babel you know how most of us we all
want to learn a second language but then
it's hard
because we tried it in high schools
tough some of us tried it in college it
was tough
some of us even tried like you know
different phone apps in the car and it's
really tough
but what i like about babel is they make
it really easy because it's designed by
over a hundred language experts and i
usually didn't like
uh language apps because i'm like how am
i gonna
learn how to speak and pronounce things
correctly
on a dang app but what's cool about
babble is they got exactly that
they help you with your pronunciation
they listen to it the ai
says oh you gotta say this way and they
correct you and it's
like pretty awesome yeah and what i like
is they break it down
into 15 minute lessons so they're
digestible
you could do it during a commute during
a jog during run so it's not like these
big
long courses because some of them were
like in order to finish the course you
have to listen to an hour or something
like that and every time i learn a new
language i want to learn
like the practical conversational like i
don't want to learn the textbook stuff
because not only is that boring but i
don't feel like
people normal people don't speak this
way yeah so they teach you like
actual conversation and things that you
can use and i think that's pretty
awesome
yeah it's super awesome and right now
they're giving you guys a special offer
through us
which is if you buy three months you get
another three months for free
just go to babel that's b a b b e l dot
com
slash off the record use the code off
the record to get
six months for the price of three and
learn another language and they got 14
different languages on there so go ahead
and choose the one that's going to
benefit you
i've been checking out spanish so of
course i could speak to jill's mom
and take a little bit more so make sure
you go check that out babble.com off the
record
nikki's parents like 57. yeah yeah
super young year old
when she had naked joe rogan's age yeah
man that's crazy
her podcast is dope
your podcast is sick that's great it's
weird to see your my parents
like get older too like i see my mom now
she's like she's like 65
and she's pretty young and vibrant but
now she's like complaining like oh yeah
like this hurts
i can't do this all the time my hands
hurt from clinging all the time
and you can see it her face is slowly
getting a little more wrinkled and you
your singer kind of like nag about more
[ __ ] you're like all right cool
this is like a real possibility that you
start thinking about as they get older
and my dad
he could like barely walk but he lives
in like taiwan and he's like doing stuff
he can't walk
he i don't know dude he had a he had a
stroke like a couple years ago
and then he has like some hip issue he
can't really walk and he's like seeing
all these experts like but eastern
medicine people like
he wants the chicken yeah yeah you don't
want the chinese
wizards yeah he doesn't want like mris
he wants [ __ ]
incense he wants to cheat right he wants
the chief my dad also
you know how you said like you can't
imagine like if you don't know if you
want to get there yeah my dad's been
staying for years
and this is just my dad because we've
always talked about death uh just even a
little kid and joked about it he's like
i just need five more years and i'm good
and then five years passes
i need to fight for all just five more i
don't want to be like he doesn't want to
be like just
feeble and [ __ ] you know so he's like
just five more he's like i had a good
life just five more years and i'm like
dad
do you want this grandkid or not you
know sandra did we try to get on his ass
about just working out more and he's
like
i'm all right i'm like dad if you if
you're pressuring me to have this
grandkid
and i'm finally gonna give it to you you
better not be one of these [ __ ] like
you better not
um give me five more years when she's
just really beginning to play with you
and then bounce like you better get
healthy bro like i need you to be around
for a little while longer and he's like
no you're making me feel bad
i'm like good yeah you gotta guilt trip
them yeah man eat some broccoli yeah
eat some vegetables [ __ ] does he
not eat right or anything he
he doesn't not eat right but he could
eat better
right because he he loves food just like
you know my mom's a great cook
and um you know he has high blood
pressure
and um i got high cholesterol because i
[ __ ] love food and [ __ ] too
um and i think he's one of those that
like even though he knows he should
watch it a little more he's also like
dude i want to enjoy if i'm getting up
there and life is getting shorter i want
to enjoy my time here have a little
crack
yeah just a little crack just one hit or
crack that'll get them to work out a
little more
yeah there you go kind of you have to do
it with them you gotta be like dad i'ma
come over and we're gonna just walk and
talk for 10 minutes yeah [ __ ]
bowl of salad come over and smoke some
crack together yeah
then we'll go walk
that's the tough part yeah the way i can
tell my parents are getting older is
that like when they come over
to my house and they they stay with us
like the room that they occupy in
starts to smell like my grandma like
there's a smell that they they have like
you know like old smell when they were
younger
they definitely didn't have the smell
but now it's like when i when i hug them
like there's that old person smelling
where does that come from it's not the
clothes i mean medicine maybe
maybe it's the medicine there's sheets
maybe
it smells like rubber shoes a little bit
i thought it was because the clothes
were so old like a vintage thrift shop
because my grandma smells like a [ __ ]
thrift shop yeah
i wish when she was alive yes moth balls
and thrift shops do your
do your parents as actually do your
parents now and your grandparents or
they hand wash all their clothes
no no so that's just my parents are cool
continue continuing
do they have a washboard and [ __ ] like
this too is that
american girl stream my dude for like
mama has a bucket in the bathtub and she
just like washes her clothes
in the bathtub in her little bucket how
long does it take her to do laundry
she has like seven shirts no no she has
she has like
she she likes to dress up she likes to
do all her stuff but she
she swears by it keeping her clothes
like perfect pristine if you buy
anything from h
m it will not last like no
[Laughter]
[ __ ] up oh [ __ ]
i do that when i travel so like i don't
want to pack
like a lot of clothes right so if i've
been wearing this for like three days
i'll just go in the shower
and with the soap in the hotel i just
have my clothes on and i just [ __ ]
start washing everything and i pull off
the shirt and then i [ __ ] wring it
out
boom and i just hang it for some reason
that's the easiest thing for me to
picture you do
doing i feel like i've seen you do that
you know what's perfect for that like
camper clothes yeah if you buy
like columbia or north like those kind
of weird yeah you can wash it and it
looks like you put it in a washing
machine and it dries quick to
certain materials that um they're like
anti-funk
right yeah like yes like the bacteria
doesn't hang and [ __ ]
yeah yeah like there's some underwear
company where they're like
oh you can wear this for i don't know
like a week and it won't get much
it's got copper in or something like
that in the fabric every i think we've
covered it here i don't want anything
that that's good
yeah yeah i like having fresh clothes
yeah yeah
i don't need to know are you willing to
go on record and say that that's a weird
secret to have
yeah yeah you know how like
traditionally people live
near families or like maybe this is an
l.a thing right but then like
it's so expensive that you gotta spread
or people come here from far away to
like make it or whatever
but like when you grow up in your own
hometown you kind of
live near your parents and then you grow
your family that way and you get like
big families
um do you guys ever see yourself doing
that
because that seems more like town and
country living in like middle america
living
versus like la new york living so that's
why
chia wants to have like three more kids
because
she comes from a big family up in canada
like you know she has like two siblings
and a lot of little cousins running
around
and so out here all her friends are
basically my friends
you know so she doesn't really have her
own squad she's going to grow her own
squad she's like i just want to make my
own little tribe out here
that's cool all right man [ __ ] how many
kids do you want
i'm down yeah you know well maybe he has
a lot of sperm
look i would have been down um yeah i do
i think
that's why i jack off so much too like i
need to get it out man
oh but i i you know look i'd be down to
just to have r1 but then also like i'm
not against
having more and like she from the
beginning she's like man i want to have
like four
and i've never been like anti-bat you
know what i'm saying four's a good
number
yeah and she always said we're gonna
have for some reason she's like we're
gonna have four daughters and as soon as
she said that like years ago it's like
yeah you're right i felt it i felt like
a chill go throughout my whole body
you have to pay for your crimes yeah
exactly where's curse man you know what
that is the player's curse
[Laughter]
all these little all these little like
i'm gonna have these little smart
cute funny daughters they're gonna have
ass like their mom
[Laughter]
i can't wait it's going to be so funny
to watch you like like have to deal with
all that [ __ ] i know
all the guys all the boyfriends yeah
let's get something great when they come
the first guy who comes over who reminds
you of yourself
you're like i know what you're capable
of yeah sick [ __ ]
you're short funny hilarious
[ __ ] get out of here
what do you got to think about putting
in your ear anyway well why why why why
are you like this
if i had all daughters and i had no sons
i
i would i'd be like i can't wait for you
to bring a boyfriend home so i can like
make him my son and i i could do all the
[ __ ] that i've been wanting to do
because like if all of my girls aren't
tomboys and they just want to do
like more traditionally girly stuff and
then like
a play but then i want my own set of
friends too you know
yeah so i'm going to be like go get a
[ __ ] boyfriend bring some taika
you're like
oh tiger's got damn
you know what's wild about this year is
that like so many people like friends
and friends of friends like had kids
like this year yeah yeah and what if
they all date each other
yeah so it's also trippy to think like
so in like 15 years from now
there's going to be a whole classroom
full of kids right who are like oh [ __ ]
we're all pandemic babies
yeah yeah because they were all born the
same time like wow all of our parents
were just at home
[ __ ] because they had nothing else to
do just trapped in their houses
yeah and like it's so weird that
everybody had babies at the same time
and it's kind of lit that like oh like
you know my boy eric has one-year-old
twins you got taika it's like
if we wanted to we could just make this
little like little classroom of kids you
know yeah that'd be tight
and you guys can all become youtube
dynasty people by marrying off your kids
to each other and building your wealth
what a premise dude i don't know what
the hell happened to my friend tim this
is not the guy
i was gonna tell a squirt story too we
were talking about laundry okay yeah
okay
now he's gone thank you one time dude
we're talking about like washing clothes
on trips um
i was this was during my groupie stage
in my life right well not like you know
just
yeah my groupie saved my life i was kind
of out there wow i
[Laughter]
like this was like height youtube
touring
and like just and i was single everyone
knew it was all just out there and um
there's one girl
only like squirter i ever hooked up with
but i didn't know she was like a
squirter you know what i'm saying
they wet the bed yeah so okay so here's
what happened like it was we're just
kind of
gonna knock it out real quick so i
didn't even get naked i just pulled my
pants around my ankles right
and then like but here's the thing i
loved these sweats
so much and then so when she squirted
at me i was like half of me was like oh
this is this is tight this has never
happened before i've never dealt with
this movie half was like
[ __ ] these are my favorite sweats ah
i didn't have a washing machine because
i was at the hotel did you climb in the
shower
no i just like well i didn't know i
thought in my head i'm like oh like
i don't know what this is what this
substance is right so i just kind of
hung them nobody knows
it doesn't know nobody does it yeah so
does it just color them it's not pee-pee
some people say it's pee some people say
it's not yeah what is it
it's it's it's it's been debated we
gotta ask
like shambody yeah yeah she was here
last week we should have just asked her
so i just like i draped him like on like
a chair
and then like but like a day later i'm
like ah this smells like this smells
like pee
so i just i didn't even i didn't want to
put them in my that's what i thought it
just felt so good that piss came out
it's different but it's not it's p but
it's not it's not 100
because then like the porn stars will
say like when they have a squirting
scene they got to drink like
like like bottles and bottles of water
to prepare and [ __ ]
so that sounds like pistols sounds like
pee dude these [ __ ] are just peeing
on us and then they're telling us oh
yeah you may become real hard
i'm a squirter sorry
yeah because where if this wasn't a
fluid
like is i've never heard of this uh
squirting sack
existing in the woman that you know like
us we have come
that's like we know where it's from yeah
we know where it took the class
right i don't see a squirting side
it's piss right it's got to be pissed
it's for sure
p that just you know it's coming out
it's hot
that means they're all squirters then
yeah like a squirrel
squirt they're peeing back
no matter what the topic this team we'll
figure it out
we got to the bottom of video
you